good morning John I hope that you don't
mind this video today is not for you it
is for the aliens good morning aliens
I'm sure that your alien life and all of
your alien business has you very busy so
I wanted to give you a really quick sort
of primer on our species so that maybe
just save you some research time while
standing our height is roughly three
point seven seven times ten to the tenth
times the average radius of a hydrogen
atom
assuming that hydrogen atoms are the
same size where you are as they are for
us which we think that probably should
be we move around on to lower appendages
called legs we have two upper appendages
called arms and each of those arms have
five appendages on them which we use to
manipulate objects a final appendage on
the top of our body contains the
majority of our sensing organs we can
detect chemicals in the air which we
call smell we can detect chemicals by
direct contact which we call taste we
can take in and perceive a certain range
of wavelengths of light and we can sense
vibrations carried through the air sound
or vibrations carried through the air is
the most important way that humans
communicate we also communicate by
transferring the sounds that we make
into symbols which we can perceive
visually and understand our auditory
forms of communication are called
languages unfortunately many are spoken
and if two people speak two different
languages those two people will find it
very difficult to communicate we get the
energy necessary for continuing our life
by consuming other organisms some of
these organisms get their energy
directly from our star those are called
plants but other organisms that we
consume are more like us production of
these food organisms requires a great
deal of the available land area and
fresh water on our planet what our
bodies are fueled by the consumption of
our organisms our society is currently
fueled mostly by hydrocarbon compounds
that we find inside of our planet these
compounds are burned to create the
energy necessary to heat and cool our
dwellings produced like produced goods
communicate with each other and move
stuff including ourselves around our
planet we are mortal all of us die and
so we must reproduce to pass our genetic
information to the next generation -
humans are required for this process a
male and a female male deposits his
genetic material inside of the female
where it is mixed together and becomes a
new human it's one of our very favorite
things to do we enjoy this process a
great deal human pairs will often bond
for life though they are not always
male-female couples many times they are
female female or male man humanity also
very much likes to bond together into
groups these groups are very much like
organisms and themselves they pass
different ideas and worldviews among
themselves and between generations some
of these groups live together in
geographically defined areas those areas
are known as country countries contain
people who are all led by this
govenor countries will also occasionally
go to war together which means that they
will systematically attempt to kill
humans inside of another country in
order to bring down that government the
most common reasons for this are to
spread an ideology or to protect the
citizens of your own country or to gain
control of natural resources such as the
hydrocarbon compounds that I mentioned
or in our world is almost universally
recognized as a brutality yet we
continued the practice and it's worth
learning that war has been a key factor
in the continuing technological
development of our civilization people
also organize themselves into groups
based on what deity they believe in if
you don't know what a deity they are
divine all-powerful leaders who control
everything but don't let themselves be
known except indirectly not all humans
believed in deities but most do our
society functions largely on the trading
of goods we use something called money
to facilitate this trading money is
represented by pieces of paper sometimes
metal disks and more and more commonly
money is just a series of numbers that
is kept track of in our global network
without money it's difficult to acquire
food and shelter and other basic needs
and there are still people in our world
who regularly die because of their lack
of money most of us continue to find
this very troubling but our attempts to
find better solutions have not been
entirely successful we're running low on
fresh water we're also running low on
the hydrocarbons that power our planet
alternatives such as directly converting
sunlight into energy and using the power
locked within atoms are either dangerous
or not feasible we have some experience
with the problems of population being
solved by starvation or disease or war
humans find this extremely distasteful
if you have any guidance for us please
send along any ideas that you have for
our culture to make it through to the
next stage of development thank you for
listening thank you for your time and
have a nice day however you measure days
John I'll see you on Wednesday
John nerdfighters in comments below or
possibly in a video response I would
like to know what you would say to the
aliens if you had a chance to talk to
them because I found that a really
interesting exercise